MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Please join
me in welcoming Sal Scognamillo.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Thank you.
Very happy to be here.
Thank you so much, Michael.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: And
hopefully, a few of you
had the opportunity
to check out-- there
were some food
items that were made
in the One cafe, some escarole,
zucchini, broccoli rabe,
some pasta-- chi chi?
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Chi chi, yes.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN:
I'm not Italian--
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Chickpeas.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: I'm
trying to learn Italian.
Zucchini pie.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Yes.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Any
of those your favorites?
SAL SCOGNAMILLO:
I love all that.
Zucchini is one of
my favorites, too,
either the pie or the scapesce
style, very, very tasty.
Something different, and
it's all grandpa's recipes,
you know.
And him and my grandmother
started this restaurant.
I don't know how they
had the fortitude
in the middle of World War II.
They were doing this.
And it's just amazing because
they did the hard work.
And then I really just have
to keep the car on the road,
so to speak.
And I also want to thank Google
for having me here today.
This is wonderful.
I'm very, very honored
to be with them.
And thank you for
interviewing me as well.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Absolutely.
You know, Patsy's
is associated with,
as I said, many celebrities
who continue to go and enjoy
the food to this day.
Probably one of the most
legendary celebrities
that Patsy's is known as
having the honor to serve
is a gentleman
named Frank Sinatra.
And, you know, there's a
really great video clip.
Sal has put up a few
video clips on YouTube.
And I wanted to
share this before we
talk a little bit about Frank.
But there's a clip of Sal
telling the story on YouTube
about how he first met
Frank Sinatra when he was
a little boy at the restaurant.
So why don't we
play that, and then
we can talk a little bit about
Frank and other celebrities?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-And he says, hey-- hey, Sal,
you want to meet Frank Sinatra?
I'm 13 years old.
I said, OK, no problem.
And my job was to get him in.
He had a secret entrance here.
I had to get him
in the side door
and bring him up to the second
floor dining room, an entrance
to come in here.
We'd put him in this
room, close the curtains.
No one knew he was here.
And I had the key to the door.
And I can remember
it to this day
because I didn't sleep
for two days afterwards.
I was trying to get
that key in the door.
I was jiggling.
I was so nervous, so
nervous, because he
wanted to shake my hand.
He says, hey, kid.
How are you?
You're Joe's son.
And all I had was
one thing on mind.
I want to get him in the door,
make sure I don't screw this up
for my family.
And I finally did,
and it was fun.
And he shook my hand.
It was a lot of laughs.
And then, the first
time I cooked for him,
I was about 22 years old.
My father was in the
dining room with him.
My father had a suit on.
My father was a chef before me.
So Sinatra says to
my dad, he says,
Joe, what are you
doing with a suit?
You've got to go in the
kitchen and cook for me.
He says, no, my kid
Sal took over that.
He says, let me go see him.
I'm in the kitchen here,
minding my own business.
The door swings open.
I look up.
It's Frank Sinatra.
I said, oh, hi.
He said, hey, kid.
I says, yes, Mr. Sinatra?
He says, make sure you cook
as good as your pop does.
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: What were
some of the other dishes Frank
liked?
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: He like stuffed
artichoke, which I just made.
I taped the other day
on Meredith Vieira.
I'm going to be on March 17th.
And I guess it's appropriate
it's St. Patrick's Day, so it
was green food.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN:
Artichoke, right.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: And he
liked the veal Milanese was
his favorite for a main course.
It's a scallopini of veal,
very thin, flour, eggs,
seasoned bread crumbs,
fried until it was crisp.
He really-- I mean, he ate
more or less everything.
One of the things, towards
the end of his life,
he couldn't eat as
much-- eating the garlic.
So anything I made
for him with garlic,
I would saute the whole
cloves in the olive oil just
to get the flavor, and
take out the garlic then,
and add the tomatoes.
Or if it was to the artichokes
or anything like that.
It's just amazing.
We say it's the restaurant
made famous by Frank Sinatra.
And we're so lucky that if
you come into the restaurant,
you see there's a lot of
celebrity photos on the wall.
And almost every one of
them could be connected
to Frank one way or another.
Like he brought in Frankie Valli
in 1962, the year I was born.
He was coming to our
restaurant 54 years now
because Frank brought
him the first time.
He brought Tony Bennett.
He brought Rosemary Clooney.
He brought George Clooney.
And it's really amazing.
I mean, my father just told me
recently-- I wish my father--
you know, he
remembers everything,
but do you have to sort of get
it out of him to talk about it.
He was telling me that 1969,
after the astronauts landed
on the moon, and then they
had the parade in downtown New
York, Frank brought
him to Patsy's.
And it's amazing.
Even to this day, someone
who you might not realize
is a big Sinatra
fan is P. Diddy.
And he started coming in
because he loves Frank.
And with a city of 20,000
restaurants, I mean,
you have to have the good
food, the good service, and all
those things, of course.
But to have somebody
walk through that door
the first time-- and
hopefully, then you
do your job to keep
them coming back.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Absolutely.
So he walked in the door
the first time when?
It was before you were 13
and you got him in the door.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Yes, of course.
Well, you know, my
grandfather first met him.
My grandfather had a
restaurant for two years
before he opened Patsy's
from 1942 to 1944
called the Sorrento.
And my grandfather had a little
bit of a reputation in business
because he was a manager, he
was a waiter, he was a busboy.
He worked in all
different restaurants.
So he had a little
bit of a following.
And there was a man
named Tommy Dorsey.
He was a bandleader who was
pretty responsible for starting
off Frank Sinatra.
And he brought Sinatra to
my grandfather back in 1942
and said, hey, Patsy.
I got this skinny
kid from Hoboken.
I want you to fatten
him up for me.
And that started a
great relationship.
Even Michael Buble comes in
now because he loves Sinatra
as well.
That's how he started coming in.
And he didn't
really become famous
until after Frank passed away.
One of the things that grandma
and grandpa always taught us,
though, was that-- and it
may sound a little bit hokey
in today's climate--
but this was just
a bigger version of their home.
This was the food
they cooked at home.
You had a bigger kitchen
and a bigger dining room,
but you want to welcome
these people as family.
And, if you go back
to what I just said,
there's 20,000 restaurants.
You know, I have to go
over and thank those people
for making the decision
to walk through that door.
You know, it's a big deal to us.
And we never take it lightly.
We never rest on our laurels.
We want to make sure every meal
was as good as the last one
that they had because,
you know, they
can choose not to come back.
That's part of it.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Well, I've
certainly experienced that.
I mean, I think from the
beginning when I've been
coming, since the mid-'90s,
the second time I came in, they
remembered me.
Sal's father, Joe, who still
works at the front a lot
remembered.
He didn't know my name.
He probably called
me kid or something,
but he remembered me.
And I think to this day,
that's such a theme at Patsy's.
You treat everybody like family.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: We try.
We really do.
And, you know, like you were
saying in the beginning,
it's our only location,
Patsy's Italian Restaurant.
Other places, Patsy Pizza
is not affiliated with us.
It's a long story.
I won't bore you
with the details.
But it's important to us.
The recipes are the same.
The heart of the
menu is the same.
Most of the supplies
I buy are the same.
But one of the things that I
want to thank Michael publicly
here is that he
was the first one
to go on social media,
things like that.
And we have the Facebook and
the Twitter and Instagram.
And of course, my
kids know better
than I do how to do that stuff.
But it's amazing how
much you get from that.
I mean, it's also helped us
to shift more of our energy
and resources a little
bit away from advertising,
traditional sense, to
advertising this way
and getting customers
this way, which is great.
Back in '94, which was
our 50th anniversary,
we came out with
the sauce, which
was a product of our customers
always asking us, gee,
you have such a
great tomato sauce.
Can you put it in a jar?
And up until then, there
really wasn't anything
that-- I know my father wasn't
going to do it on his own.
And we had to twist
his arm to do it.
But this was something that
now, believe it or not,
brings customers to us.
People can buy this
in supermarkets
across the country.
And if they bought in California
and are heading to New York,
they want to try our place.
And that's another way of
getting to see where we are.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN:
Well, and I would
say you're probably
not giving yourself
enough credit on social media.
If you go to the
Facebook page, you'll
see Sal is really a master
at sharing things, which
is what we really want.
You want to see a
great plate of pasta.
And you share some amazing
dishes on social media.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Recipe Monday
every Monday on Facebook.
Almost 9 times out of 10,
that gets the most hits.
I mean, really, that's
what it comes down to is
you want to have the good food.
You want to have
a good experience.
You're not spending your
hard earned dollars not
to enjoy yourself, of course.
And being in the
theater district
is helpful, right by Carnegie
Hall, all the major theaters.
It's always been a great area.
It's only gotten better
throughout the years.
And even the website, we get
so many hits on the website.
People find.
They want to see a menu.
They want to see what
kind of food you have.
And it's something that, really,
we try and keep up to date
as much as we can with it.
Like I said, my children
are better at this as well.
And god willing, they may
be the fourth generation.
My older boy loves business.
He's second year in college now.
And the younger one is
a senior in high school,
and he wants to cook.
So I said to my
father-- I always
tease my dad, who's been working
here for the whole 72 years,
by the way.
I said, I think I'm going
to retire before you.
And when I say that,
I have to duck.
But it's great.
I mean, I'm lucky to be
with my family as well.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Well, back
to Frank Sinatra for a second.
So every year, you have
a birthday celebration
on Frank's birthday.
You had the 100th
celebration just recently,
which became a whole week.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Yes.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Maybe
tell me a little bit
about how that came to be.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: We
always celebrated
his birthday, December 12th.
And this year was a special one
because, as you just mentioned,
he turned 100.
So we had Sirius XM, we
had Siriusly Sinatra,
the station devoted to him.
They came in and we did
a three hour live show.
And Steve Tyrrell was the host.
And we had several
people calling in,
but the first caller was Tina
Sinatra, Frank's daughter,
which was fun.
And it's just amazing how
he's influenced so many
other artists now these days.
I mentioned P. Diddy before.
If you look at some of the
commercials-- I believe
it's for Ciroc vodka--
"Luck Be a Lady"
is playing in the background.
So it's just a timeless thing.
And if you could ask for a
better PR person than him,
I don't know if you could
find someone to promote you.
And it's something
that if he liked you,
you didn't want for anything.
So it was really a lot of fun.
And that celebration,
like you said,
because so many
people wanted to come,
we did five different
parties because we
couldn't fit everyone into
the restaurant on the one day.
But it was wonderful.
And it's just a thing
we're so proud and honored
to carry on as well.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: So
reserve now for next year.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Next
year, put it down.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: The 101st.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Yes.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Now,
I would imagine, then,
you have a story or two
of Frank Sinatra, above
and beyond what we saw in
the video of meeting him.
There was probably
some great moments.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO:
So many fun things.
I mean, with my experience,
when I was 16, 1978,
New York Yankees won
the World Series.
They called up my
father, Joe, and said
Billy Martin, the manager,
wanted to bring the whole team.
They made a reservation
for 50 people.
Upstairs can be parties
of two, four, six, or so.
It could be separated.
The back room with
Sinatra-- actually,
the front of the restaurant.
Sinatra used to sit, would
be about 30, 35 people.
The other section,
you could do 50.
So when the Yankees
arrived, my father
had them set up in the
front part of the room.
And he congratulated them.
They won the World Series.
And Billy Martin, the
manager, said to my father,
well, why don't
we sit over there?
We're supposed to
sit back there.
He's pointing
behind the curtain.
And my father was
trying to be diplomatic,
but he didn't
realize what he said.
He said, I have that saved
for someone really important.
So Billy Martin was really
angry with my father.
And obviously, a few minutes
later, we got the signal.
Sinatra would come in
the private entrance.
And Sinatra was
coming up the steps,
and Billy Martin was
face to face with him.
And Billy Martin, of
course, was the Yankees.
And Sinatra, people don't
realize, was a Dodgers fan.
Yanks just beat the Dodgers.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Oh boy.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: So he wasn't
happy to see Billy Martin.
And he said, what the
hell are you doing here?
And Billy Martin, for the
first time in his life,
was tongue tied, a
little tongue tied.
And Sinatra walked back behind
the curtain with his party.
And then Billy Martin
came over to my father,
instead of being angry, he said,
I want to meet Frank Sinatra.
My father said,
you just met him.
He says, yeah, but
I got tongue tied.
So my father asked Frank.
He says, it's OK.
Just bring Billy
back, no one else.
I'm a little tired.
I flew in from the West Coast.
My father told
Billy to come back.
And Billy Martin, being
Billy Martin-- those of you
who knew him-- was a hothead.
He stepped up on top
of one of the tables
and said to the
whole team, come on.
We're going to
meet Frank Sinatra.
And it took him a whole hour.
And he was just very
patient and very nice.
He congratulated everyone.
And Yanks ate their dinner
and Sinatra ate his dinner.
Normally, that would be
the end of the story.
About three hours go by.
Frank gets up, pulls
the curtain back,
waves goodbye to
the Yankee team.
Yankee team applauds
him and he leaves.
Billy Martin comes
over to my dad.
He said, oh my god.
That was-- what a special
night we just had.
We won the World Series, we
ate at Patsy's restaurant,
and we met Frank Sinatra.
He says, we weren't going
to leave until Frank left.
He says, now that Frank had
left, he says, we can go.
Can I please have the check?
My father hesitated
for a second.
He says, I'm sorry,
Billy, I can't do that.
Frank picked it up for you.
The whole team.
He bought dinner
for the whole team.
He was-- he was a great man.
I mean, you know, if he didn't
like someone, stay away.
But if he liked you,
you were in good shape.
You were in good shape.
But it really is, for me,
it's-- I'm a very lucky person.
I mean, I get to do what I love.
So you say you never
work a day in your life
when you're doing that.
And I've been full time
since January of '85.
I took television
film production,
so I love this
part of it as well.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Right.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: I
couldn't get a job,
so my father said, would you
like to learn how to cook?
And, you know, that's
also a great part
about it is I wasn't
forced into the business,
as I wouldn't do for
my children as well.
And I really enjoy it.
I'm very lucky.
I meet nice people all the time.
We've become very
good friends-- I mean,
just a wonderful
byproduct of being
in this type of
business where you're
trying to make people happy.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Well,
and hearing that story,
the wonderful thing about,
I think, your cookbooks
is you integrate the
stories throughout both this
and the first cookbook,
which just adds to the flavor
and makes you want to
eat the food as you're
reading some of the stories.
How did this
cookbook come about?
I know the first cookbook did
very well, was a bestseller.
This one is an Italian
family cookbook, it's called.
How is this different
than the first one?
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Well, the
first one is more or less almost
all restaurant recipes.
This one, I try to integrate
some of our family recipes
as well, which really are what
we do there, too, but just
some of the ones that haven't
always been on the menu,
that we'll make as
specials as well.
And, you know, it was always,
for me-- even the first book,
which is this one
here, and the foreword
was written by Nancy
Sinatra, Frank's daughter--
it was about really
getting some type
of a history of the
restaurant written down,
because all these great
stories would be lost
and all the history
of it would be lost.
I mean, I really admire
what my grandparents did,
as I mentioned.
And a really funny
story is that grandpa--
he passed in '86, grandpa Patsy.
And I became a chef in '85.
And last time he was at the
restaurant was late '85.
And there was a group of
us waiting-- family members
waiting for him to come.
He lived in Jersey at the
time and he couldn't drive,
so someone drove him in.
And we were so happy grandpa
was coming to see us.
We were going to
have dinner together.
We usually eat about
3:00 in the afternoon
in between lunch and dinner.
And grandpa pulls up, and the
whole family, hey, welcome,
grandpa.
And he didn't say a word.
He walked past all of us,
walked in the kitchen,
went down the steps in the
refrigerator, came back up.
And I said, grandpa,
what happened?
He says, now I could
say hello to you.
He says, I wanted
to check and see
if you were still buying the
same veal I told you to buy.
So you know, it was that kind of
a feeling that-- and he just--
that was his life.
And used to wear this
little gray jacket.
Everyone thought
he was a busboy.
And we always say, you know,
pop, why don't you dress up?
You're the owner and stuff.
He says, no.
People won't ask me
to fill their water
or bring them the bread then.
They'll be intimidated to ask
the owner to do something.
So he was really about service,
and we just try and echo that
as well.
I mean, again, you know,
so many other restaurants
that you could go to.
Why go here?
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Well, and
you're always out in the room.
I think I've never
been there that you
didn't come out and talk to
everybody at every table.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: I always
try and make sure, go around,
everything's OK.
And if everyone's
shown up for work
and no one's on vacation or no
one's out sick, I can do that.
Because, again, my
bulk of my work, which
is making the soups, the
sauces, the things that take
time-- cutting up
the veal, the baking.
If I get all that done by
about 3:00, which I usually do,
I can go out and mingle,
which is my favorite part.
And, you know, in
case sometimes there's
a party of 20 in the back and
the captain's taking the order,
and there may be a
party of two that's
waiting a little bit longer.
And you don't want to let
that slip through the cracks
that someone's being ignored.
And, you know, again,
they're spending
their hard-earned money.
You've got to make sure
they're happy as well.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Sure.
So Patsy's Italian
Family Cookbook.
You know, I also like
being an aspiring cook.
I would never be a chef.
And I love to make Italian food.
But just some of the
nuggets of information.
I think two probably
primary ingredients
in most Italian dishes
are olive oil and garlic.
And I think there's
some interesting things
in the cookbook.
Maybe you can share, how do
you pick a good olive oil?
SAL SCOGNAMILLO:
Well, you know, it's
got to have the
right-- you know,
and people always talk
about extra virgin.
And I use that for
non-cooked dishes,
like the roast peppers,
the mozzarella, the salads,
things like that.
Because once you
start cooking it,
you don't get the
full flavor of it.
So you could use
olive oil to cook.
We use from Umbria is usually
the best region I found,
but there's so many that you
can get that are good now.
Garlic, of course, you have
to make sure it's fresh.
We take it, peel it off,
and usually chop it.
And that's the way like
a marinara is made.
And we say the holy
trinity is garlic,
oil, and tomatoes, right?
The three best ingredients.
But what's interesting is
that a lot of our sauces,
even in the jar,
the bestselling one
is the marinara,
which is the garlic.
The second best is
the tomato basil.
A lot of times, I
see companies, when
you go to market
like a pasta sauce,
they'll have three
different labels.
They'll have a spaghetti sauce,
a marinara, and a tomato basil.
It's the same sauce.
This sauce is distinctive.
The tomato basil is different
seasonings, and it's onions.
There's no garlic.
And people say, wait, wait.
Italian food has to have garlic.
And not necessarily.
Not necessarily.
Even we make a
filetto di pomodoro,
which is onion,
tomatoes, and prosciutto.
The meat sauce that
we make is a red sauce
because we're from southern
Italy, from Naples,
and that we use tomato in.
And it's onions--
again, no garlic.
I mean, if someone wants it,
of course, we can add it.
Most dishes are cooked to order,
so we can do that as well.
But it's not always so.
And my father, as
he's gotten older,
he can't digest
the garlic as well.
That's what we talked
about Frank Sinatra.
So if we make a dish, we
saute the whole cloves
to get the flavor
in the olive oil,
and then put your tomatoes
in and stuff like that.
The red sauce is the
base of the kitchen.
But the heart of
the menu is the same
as when grandma and
grandpa started.
As I mentioned before, many
of the distributors we use
are the same.
And the people we're buying
mozzarella is called Di Palo.
It's downtown on Grand Street.
And we're their longest
customer for 72 years.
Now, they've been in
business since 1920.
And they're also third
generation as well.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Wow.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: So it's
a level of consistency.
I think one compliment
that I remember
that was one of my
favorites of all time
is a steady customer who's
been coming since before I was
a chef, you know, how am I
going to feel about cooking
for someone like that?
I said, you know,
here's your table.
I hope you enjoy
everything tonight.
Sal, I know what the
food's going to taste
like before I come here.
So that was the kind of thing
that really stuck in my head
to say, you know, hey,
you've got a responsibility
to make sure it's
consistent all the time.
And we don't try to be
something we're not.
It's not a fancy,
frou frou restaurant.
But it's a good,
stick-to-your-ribs southern
Italian red sauce joint.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN:
Red sauce joint.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: As
Frank Sinatra would say.
As Sinatra would say.
And hopefully, that's
what appeals to people.
And we're lucky so far.
We're doing OK.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: I feel like
I always burn the garlic.
Is there a way-- a trick--
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: A lot of
people heat up the oil first
and then put the garlic in,
and it will burn right away.
I put it in when the oil
is still room temperature.
And then you brown it.
And if you do burn
it, it's gone.
You've got to start over.
There's no salvaging that.
Even the oil is going
to have that flavor.
And, of course, it's being
such a big flavor in a dish,
garlic has a strong flavor,
you have to redo it then.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: My mouth
is salivating just thinking
about garlic cooking, right?
SAL SCOGNAMILLO:
Garlic and oil, right?
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Are
there particular recipes
in this cookbook that are
favorites of yours that
sort of come to mind?
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: I
always default to pasta.
And, as you see, the cover
is spaghetti and meatballs.
And it's a funny story
with the meatballs.
They were off the menu
for a little while.
And I kept saying to my dad,
it was like the late '80s.
It wasn't as "chic" to have
spaghetti and meatballs,
I guess.
I don't know.
And I said to my dad, I said,
we should put them back on.
Everyone asks for
them all the time.
And we had such a
big fight over it.
He was like, no, it's
been off the menu.
And I said, look, we have this
section with the specials.
Let's try it for a few days.
If not, we just take
that section off.
And he says, I'm never
going to question you again.
We sold like 1,300
meatballs the first week.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: I ate 1,200.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Yeah,
I was going to say--
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: I love
the spaghetti and meatballs.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Well,
it's a veal meatball.
A lot of people do the
veal, beef, and pork, which
is what my mother-in-law does.
My mother makes just beef.
But Grandpa Patsy, it was veal.
And I think it was mainly
because that was what
his scrap was when he cleaned.
We used to clean the
whole leg of veal.
And you'd always have scraps.
You make the meat
sauce from that.
You chop it up and
make the meatballs.
Now the pieces come
already cleaned for you.
It's much easier.
But it's definitely-- what I've
noticed about it is it's more
gelatinous.
So it keeps it moister.
When you have the
veal meatballs,
they feel like they're
lighter and they feel moister,
you know, more juice to it.
And that's what people
seem to love about it.
That's Frankie
Valli's favorite dish.
He talked about that on-- I
think it was the YES Network.
They did an interview with him
on the Yankee network about it.
It's fun.
And, you know, I
know I've got to make
sure I make enough
meatballs when
that show airs, which is fun.
It's been great.
Since the first cookbook
came out, it was 2002.
I was able to get on TV
shows and things like that.
And again, that's
another vehicle
to let people know
about your restaurant.
I mean, as much as
sometimes you may think
people know about you, no.
It's hard to keep it relevant.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN:
Well, you certainly
have been on TV a lot.
When Tony Danza had his
show, I feel like you
were on almost every week.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Tony
Danza is so much fun.
And you know, I've
been so blessed.
I've been on the Today
Show, Martha Stewart.
As I mentioned, we're
going to be on-- I taped
a show for Meredith Vieira.
I think Tony Danza was
the only person I couldn't
teach how to cook anything.
It was funny.
He's quite a character.
Actually, I think
he got in trouble
that he talked about Patsy's
Italian Restaurant so much.
I think he got a letter
from the Olive Garden
because they're a
corporate sponsor.
They said, we're spending
hundreds of thousands
of dollars to put
ads for your show,
and you're mentioning
this one for free.
But I think that's part of the
reason he got fired because he
did whatever he wanted.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Oh boy.
Now we know the truth.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: But I'll
tell you a funny story.
How I met Tony Danza was when
the first cookbook came out,
as I mentioned, I got
a lot of interviews.
And one of the interviews I
did was with Where magazine.
It's in all the hotels, Where.
It shows you where
everything is.
And they asked me a question
I wasn't asked on an interview
before.
It was interesting.
They were looking
at the pictures
on the wall at the
restaurant and they
said, Sal, whose picture
is missing from there?
In other words, which
celebrity has never
come that you'd like to meet?
And I instantly said,
I says, oh, you know,
I've always admired Tony Danza.
He's so much fun.
He grew up on Long Island,
not far from where I grew up,
where I still live.
And somehow, that made
it into the article.
Somehow, a bartender at
a hotel he was staying at
showed him the article.
And he saw it.
He walks in with the
article in one hand,
and you could picture Tony like
this, screaming and yelling.
I see my name in the paper.
I'm here.
Where's this guy Sal?
And it was so much
fun because-- and I
didn't know whether to hug
him or hide under the table.
I says, oh my god, look at this.
And he was flattered that
I wanted to meet him.
It so boggles my mind.
It's so cool.
And we became friends,
which is nice.
And, like you said, when
he had his television show
two years in New York, I think
it was on five or six times.
It was a lot of fun.
It's a lot of fun.
You know, my kids
were younger then.
It was about 9 years
ago, 10 years ago.
We were in Disney
for a vacation.
And we're waiting on a
line for one of the rides.
And some man ran
up to me and says,
are you Sal from
Patsy's Restaurant?
I saw you on the
Tony Danza show.
Can I have your autograph?
I was like, I went over
to my wife, and says,
you told him to do this, right?
He says, no, no.
So, I mean, yeah, we
got a lot of recognition
from that one, which was
fun-- which was a lot of fun.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN:
Well, another actor,
who wrote the
foreword, Ben Stiller,
how did that connection happen?
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Well, you
know, Jerry Stiller, his father,
and Anne Meara, who
sadly passed last year,
were very close
with Frank Sinatra.
But the way they
first came in was
they did the Ed Sullivan Show.
Still and Meara
was a comedy team.
The younger ones amongst
us that don't know,
that's Ben Stiller's parents.
And they did the
Ed Sullivan Show,
which was taped with
David Letterman, where
Stephen Colbert is now.
To get on the Ed Sullivan
Show in those days
was like-- that was
the gold standard.
And to celebrate, we wanted to
go to a real, white tablecloth
restaurant.
That's the first time.
And that was in the
early '60s that they
came to our restaurant.
And they've been
coming ever since.
And they brought their children.
I mean, Ben Stiller
wrote a foreword
that it makes me cry
when I look at it.
I mean, just to condense
it real quickly, basically,
what he says is that he
remembers my grandfather.
And he was a little boy.
And he'd come with
his sister Amy.
And he'd say, what can
I make for you tonight?
You know, please sit down.
What can I make for you tonight?
And then he recounts when
my father became the chef.
And my father would
say the same thing.
What can I make for you tonight?
And when I became a chef.
And then he ends the
foreword with saying,
I can't wait for Sal's son
Peter to come and be the chef
and ask me, what can I
make for you tonight?
I mean, it's so
overwhelming to me
that these people
have such a loyalty,
and not just celebrities.
The customers,
generations of customers.
And people come in, and if they
had their children with them,
I said, oh, you made more
customers for us now.
So it's really--
I can't get over
how lucky we are that people
are so fiercely loyal to us
as well.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Sure.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO:
It's a big deal.
And in New York, if
you're open five years,
that's like a big deal.
72 years, thank god.
But as long as
people want it, we'll
be happy to keep
serving as well.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Well,
we're going to open it up
for questions in a minute.
But you know, 72
years, what's next?
We're going to have
to start planning
for the 100th
anniversary, right?
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: God
willing, we'll be here.
And yeah, like I said, my
children, I won't force them.
They're both interested.
Joseph, the older one,
likes the business aspect,
and Peter likes the
cooking aspect of it.
And god willing, if
they want to come in,
we're going to try and
continue to do this.
I mean, the way we have
branched out, as we mentioned,
the sauce and the cookbooks
and things like that.
You know, god willing,
who knows if it's
in the future, other places.
But you never know what
could happen with that.
It's always important to us
that the quality stays the same.
I mean, even when we put
this sauce in the jar,
we had this done by
co-packers, you know,
companies that do this for you.
And one of the things we always
got when we went to co-packers
is, we're already making
an Italian spaghetti sauce.
Just give us your label.
We'll slap it on there.
And you're kind of missing
the point, you know.
We want our sauce in the jar.
So that was what
was important to us.
That was the hardest thing
to convince my dad to do.
We had to twist his arm.
He says, if it's not
good, it's not coming out.
And, you know, he's right.
This is why you
are where you are.
Don't lower your standards.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: And I think
it's an indication that you
make quality food, and you've
also been open and curious
to new things.
And you've been innovative, from
the sauces to the cookbooks.
You had, I think, the
Google Maps folks came in.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: That's right.
The Google Maps did an
inside of our restaurant.
And I'm understanding that's
a big deal, which I was really
excited about.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN:
Well, it's nice
because if you don't have a
chance to go to the restaurant,
you can go online, and you can
go in the restaurant and see.
I don't know if it takes you
into the Sinatra room upstairs.
I don't remember.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO:
I don't remember
if they did that or not.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: You have to
go and experience that live.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: But
that's another way
to get another generation
that's interested.
And that's why this social
media stuff is relevant, too.
It really makes
a big difference.
I think a lot of
people tell me--
and again, I'm not so good
at this-- but they say,
we do a Google search, midtown,
family-owned, this, that.
And we pop up.
I mean, how big is that?
I mean, if you're
looking for something.
Years ago-- it's
still word of mouth,
but years ago, you relied
on a friend, or a concierge
at a hotel, or
something like that.
Now everyone has the phone or
the device to check and see.
And we've got great
reviews online
as well, which is helpful.
And that's, again, first
time to get them in.
And then hopefully, they come
back and tell their friends
as well.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: And those
pictures you post of the food
don't hurt either.
They certainly help.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: It's tempting.
It's tempting.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Do
we have any questions?
Anybody want to step up
to the mic, feel free.
While you're moving over
there, I'll ask you,
what is your favorite
thing to eat?
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: I'm always
going to default to pasta.
And I think the
rigatoni sorrentino,
which is sort of
similar to a baked ziti,
but it's with ricotta,
mozzarella, and tomato basil
sauce and Parmesan
cheese on top.
And if I'm in the mood
for a garlicky pasta,
I love the clam sauce--
very simple, garlic
and oil, the fresh clams,
a little clam water,
touch of oregano,
fresh basil, no salt
because it's salty already.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Sure.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Simple
stuff, but that's
what I'll always default to.
And that's why I'm
never going to be thin.
But don't trust a
thin chef, right?
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: That's right.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Sal.
I met you in your restaurant
I think half a year ago
when a lot of us came in there.
It's very cool to see you again.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Thank you.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: That's
why I came out here.
Yeah.
I think somebody was
like inviting you here.
He said, I want
to come to Google.
So it's good to see that happen.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: I'm so honored.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So what
are some of the most
popular off menu dishes that
people somehow know to order?
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Oh yeah.
It's a good question.
And quite often, if they call me
up and I have the ingredients,
I'll make it.
If not, give me a
day or two to get it.
And one is braciole, which
is either pork or beef.
And it's a flank.
And you cut up the pork or the
beef and you beat it down flat.
It's stuffed with
chopped beef or pork,
depending on which one, raisins,
pine nuts, garlic, and cheese.
We roll it up,
braise it in the oil,
and it slow cooks in the sauce
for about 2 and 1/2, three
hours.
That's why we always tell
you to order it before.
Another one would be lasagna.
Lasagna, classic
southern Italian dish.
We make four layers-- meatballs,
sausage, cheese, tomato sauce.
And it's a popular dish
as well people ask for.
The things that are
on the menu that you
don't see in other
places that are popular
are tripe, which is one of
the few things I don't eat.
It's honeycombed tripe.
It's the intestine of
the stomach of the cow.
But it's really a great sauce.
It's onions, peas,
and prosciutto.
And it's stewed with tomato
sauce and white wine,
very popular.
When we make the
filetto di pomodoro,
people like that, to
take it to [INAUDIBLE].
So it starts off with
onions, prosciutto, tomatoes.
And [INAUDIBLE], we
add the pancetta,
which is Italian bacon.
And I put a little bit
of regular American bacon
in there.
So you can make derivatives
of different dishes.
And again, if I have
the ingredients,
I'm more than happy to do it.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN:
There's also a dish
you make-- I don't think it's
on the menu-- with the melon.
You made that for me.
It's a great summer pasta.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO:
Prosciutto and melon sauce.
Doesn't sound that good.
And it was in the first book.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN:
It's fantastic.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: And
it's a little different.
But we had a party that had
canceled at the last minute.
And I had made
some melon wrapped
with prosciutto with the
toothpicks to pass around.
And I says, oh no.
What am I going to do?
This is all cut up already.
So we always make dinner
for the employees.
So I just took it.
I sauteed some onions,
some tomato sauce,
a little touch of fresh basil.
I put it over fresh linguine.
Everyone went crazy for it.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN:
It's really good.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO:
Sweet and salty.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: A strange
combo, but it's really good.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: It worked good.
Thank you for reminding
me about that.
I haven't made that for a while.
But it's always a pleasure.
I mean, that's for
us, we can do it.
You know, it's funny how
so many places you go to,
and you try and
substitute something,
and they don't want
to know from beans.
They don't want to know.
I have a friend of mine that's
been coming there probably
a little bit longer than you.
And I won't mention the name,
but he went to a steakhouse
with his wife and two other
couples, with six people.
And you know, they
spent a good $1,200.
And at the end of the
meal, the waitress
was taking the order
for dessert and he says,
I'd just like to
have some ice cream.
And she says, I'm sorry,
sir, we don't have ice cream.
And he said, well, you just
mentioned one of the desserts
was pie a la mode, you know, the
apple pie with the vanilla ice
cream on top.
She says, yeah, but
we can't separate it.
So he said, I'll pay
for the whole thing.
It doesn't matter.
You know, he's a wealthy man.
She says, I'm sorry,
we can't do that, sir.
And I think that's what--
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN:
I think for $1,200,
I would have gone to the store
and bought ice cream, right?
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Well, he
was embarrassed because he
was with two other couples.
But the thing is I think
that's what takes--
and a lot of people tell
us to do Open Table, which
I think we eventually will do.
But it takes the human
element out of it.
Open Table's going to
tell you Saturday night,
there is no reservation.
That's it.
But if you call me up the last
minute, and it's a party of two
and it's not a party of 10, I'm
going to say yes, of course.
I mean, we try and do that.
We always try to save a
table or two for regulars
that walk in and don't call.
I mean, we always
ask everyone to call.
It's better for the table to
wait for you than the other way
around.
And the last thing
you want to do--
and this is something that, if
I could change in this business,
I would.
It gets me crazy
when people get angry
when you don't have a table.
And I say, do you really think
I don't want your business?
I mean, I want to take care of
you, but where can I put you?
There's no perfect
solution to it.
But it's interesting when
a computer would tell you
that there's no table,
but somehow, you know,
there's going to be a no
show on a Saturday night,
something like that.
So that's a human
element, and that's
where we would give
them just the ice cream.
It would be no problem.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: We have
a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Sal.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for coming over.
I just ate, and I'm still like--
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Oh, thank you.
Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: I would like your view
on-- there's sort of a trend
nowadays about
modernist cuisine.
We often hear about
Massimo Bottura.
We heard of this
Italian chef who
does a lot of things
about molecular food.
And it seems like people are
more and more into molecular,
modernist, things
that go a little bit
beyond traditional cuisine.
And from what I hear,
it sounds like you're
more passionate about bringing
all the traditions all together
and carry on this trend.
So I'd like to get
your vision on that,
on how you see this coming
over for your restaurant,
maybe in terms of cuisine
overall in New York
or in the world.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: That's
a great question.
You know, it's funny
is that we always
say that we don't try and
be something we're not,
whether it's in life or in
terms of what our restaurant is.
You know, if every place
is opening and serving
Tuscan food, we're not going to
change the menu to suit that.
I mean, like I said, we'll
make the different dishes
that people ask for, but we
try and do the one thing,
and the one thing just right.
While on the other
hand, I think it's
wonderful to have other
things and new ideas.
And I'm always open to them,
as long as they fit into it.
And I don't know if it's just
our particular customers,
something as simple if
we change the bread,
like I try to get some
bread with the olives,
the olive loaves in there, and
some rosemary, steady customer,
where's my bread?
Where's my regular bread?
So you've got someone
coming in 25, 30 years,
you don't want to get
them upset about it.
And I tell you, the food
that I looked here today,
I'm just overwhelmed how much
food you have in this thing.
I think, as much as
I'm already overweight,
I think I'd be another 100
pounds if I worked here.
But it's wonderful.
It's a great idea to
keep those things going.
And different combinations
are all wonderful.
My younger son is so good.
He loves that show, Chopped.
And he could look
at those ingredients
and just figure something
out, where I don't know.
It just doesn't
work with my brain.
But he can come up with
something really right away.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: Thank you.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: I wanted
to maybe get one more Sinatra
story out of you,
because I think
there's a moment where your dad
was very sensitive to an artist
or performer who was kind of
down on his luck at the time.
And something happened that
I think is a great story.
So maybe you could share that.
I think you know which
one I'm talking about.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: This
was before I was born.
It was the early '50s.
And a lot of people don't
realize Frank Sinatra was down
on his luck.
I mean, he was
basically finished.
The industry thought
he was finished.
He had lost his voice.
He had lost the record contract.
Ava Gardner just
broke up with him.
That was his love of his life.
And he would come to the
restaurant by himself.
And he'd say to my grandfather,
Patsy, sit with me.
I don't want to eat by myself.
I don't want to be here.
He'd point to the other
customers and say,
these people are all my
fair weather friends.
They only come when the sun is
shining, when I'm doing good.
These are the people that
would want to buy me a drink
or pay for my dinner.
Now they ignore me.
And my grandfather always
used to reassure him and say,
Frank, you know, you'll
make a comeback someday.
And this was right before
"From Here to Eternity,"
which was his comeback.
The next day was Thanksgiving.
And to this day, we're still
closed on Thanksgiving.
It's one of the few
holidays we're closed.
And Frank Sinatra said to my
grandfather Patsy, he says,
I want to come in tomorrow.
Book me a table for one.
My grandfather had signs
up all over the place
that they're closed
the next day,
but he didn't have
the heart to tell
Frank Sinatra they were closed.
And he would invite him
over to his house, which
he had been a million times.
And he says, OK,
Frank, no problem.
He took the signs down.
He told all the waiters.
He says, if it's possible,
can you come in tomorrow?
And there was
moaning and groaning.
It's Thanksgiving.
He said, bring your family.
It's for Frank Sinatra.
He's coming in.
I don't want him to
be here by himself.
And they did.
And the next day, he walked in.
And you know, it's 3
o'clock in the afternoon.
Could you picture
this in the '50s?
Italian restaurant.
And he says to my
grandfather, hey, Patsy,
it's a little quiet today.
No one in the place.
I mean, think about it.
And he ate dinner.
And he found out later in life
that my grandfather opened just
for him, and he never forgot it.
He never forgot it.
He was very, very
loyal about that.
And he did make his comeback
when he did "From Here
to Eternity," and he
never went back down.
It was right to the moon.
All good stuff.
Very, very amazing.
And these are the ones that
my father can remember.
So got to get him to sit down
one day with my video camera
and take some more
stories from him.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Well, Sal,
thank you for sharing with us.
The cookbook is amazing,
Patsy's Italian Family Cookbook.
I have both of them, of course.
And I encourage you to
go to Patsy's anytime.
Now you know you can
go at the last minute
and ask for Sal, right?
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: You're in.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: And there's
many, many, many, many, many,
many more stories, from Frank,
to Ben Stiller and beyond,
and Buble.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: What's really
nice, though, about-- we didn't
get into too much
about the cookbooks--
is that, especially this one's
been out longer, the first one.
Is that people use them.
They say to me, this book is
all dirty with sauce stains
on it and stuff.
I'm using it.
And it's ingredients I know
and recipes I can make.
And I tell people,
don't be intimidated.
I mean, you know, I made the
lasagna on Martha Stewart,
as I mentioned to you.
And it's not difficult.
It's just time consuming.
You can do it.
It's not crazy ingredients.
It's stuff you probably
already have in your cabinet.
And that's why I think
it's been a success.
And you know, it's really fun.
It's really fun.
I'm very lucky.
Every day, I wake up and
can't believe how lucky I am.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN:
Well, thank you.
And I know you're going
to sign some books.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO:
Oh, I'd love to.
I'd love to.
That would be great.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: Obviously,
if you haven't already,
check out Patsy's
on their website,
and on Facebook and
Twitter and Instagram.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO: All
those good things.
MICHAEL KAUFFMAN: All the above.
Sal, thank you.
SAL SCOGNAMILLO:
Thank you very much.
My pleasure.
Pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]